d'inspiration italienne la construction
de ce château a duré plus de 150 ans
156 mètres de façade 4 grosses tours
d'angles des tourelles qui s'élancent
dans le ciel Chambord et le plus grand
duos des châteaux de la Loire la visite
coûte très euros par adulte la famille a
réservé un guide pour un supplément de 5
euros par personne il s'appelle Aurélien
et Valais emmener dans un voyage au cœur
de l'histoire alors on vient de rentrer
en château qu'est-ce qu'on voit en
premier quand on rentre dans le château
de Chambord
on voit des grands escaliers alors les
enfants je vous propose qu'on fasse un
petit jeu vous allez monter de ce côté
et vous allez vous arrêter à la première
fenêtre avec vos parents on va monter de
l'autre côté et on va voir ce qui va se
passer allez-y
cet escalier est unique à Chambord on
l'appelle l'escalier à double révolution
en fait on y monte et on y descend sans
jamais se croiser grâce à deux rampes
distinctes le centre est creux des
fenêtres ont été placées les unes en
face des autres toute la petite famille
peut se voir
alors on va monter les étages les
enfants montent de plus en plus vite ils
veulent arriver les premiers tout en
haut mais c'était sans compter sur la
rapidité de leur papa arrivait avant eux
[Musique]
la récompense c'est maintenant sur l'une
des terrasse emblématiques du château
elle offre une vue imprenable sur les
jardins de 7 hectares qui viennent juste
d'être rénovés
à Chambord tout est démesuré y compris
l'intérieur
426 pièces des suites royales les
visiteurs peuvent même imaginer grâce à
une application de réalité augmentée ce
qu'était la vie dans ce château au 16e
siècle
[Musique]
la famille de Marlène et Mickaël va
aussi découvrir une des pièces les plus
énigmatiques de ce château si beau si
imposant et si puissant que le Roi
Soleil aménager une chambre
on arrive dans la chambre de Louis XIV
et regardez la petite balustrade en fait
ça servait à séparer l'endroit où dormez
le roi de l'espace où tous les autres
tous les invités pouvaient rentrer juste
à côté du lit vous voyez la petite porte
qui est caché
ah oui on a une pièce secrète ici qui
était réservée au roi et ben on va y
aller ensemble une pièce secrète
uniquement réservée au roi mais pour y
arriver il faut ressortir sur la
terrasse et ouvrir une porte dans la clé
est énorme c'est ici dans cette pièce
que le roi pouvait vivre à l'abri des
regards ici c'était les parties privées
réservées au roi de France et regardez
on a une petite porte qui est caché ici
à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver
derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retour à la case départ directement dans
la chambre du roi la famille en prend
plein les yeux
on sent vraiment tout petit donc voilà
on s'efface et on laisse le décor opérer
voilà et nous permet de s'émerveiller
devant lui tandis que la famille part
vers d'autres aventures à quelques
mètres de là sur une terrasse du château
voici
Eric il est chercheur et passionné
d'histoire il travaille à Chambord
depuis 30 ans il est le seul à détenir
le code secret pour ouvrir les pièces du
château que le grand public ne peut pas
encore voir
et là nous quittons les espaces publics
pour aller vers des espaces plus privés
une des missions d'Éric et de comprendre
à quoi servaient les combles du château
on n'a pas de commentaires de l'époque
qui nous raconterait comment les nobles
vivaient dans les combles et pourtant on
sait que ça a été parfois le cas la
seule chose qu'un témoigne encore
aujourd'hui c'est la présence d'énormes
cheminées qui sont les mêmes cheminées
que dans les étages inférieurs donc
vraiment on est dans les espaces
d'habitation noble même dans les combles
sur une des terrasses une porte dérobée
mène à la plus haute tour de Chambord
pour y monter comme par tout ailleurs
dans le château des marches en tuto une
pierre très fragile
cette tour est la tour de la lanterne
avec une immense fleur de lys à son
sommet une tour très étroite dont Eric
tente chaque jour de comprendre à quoi
elle servait à l'époque de François 1er
cette histoire il voudrait un jour la
raconter aux visiteurs
mais lorsqu'on constate aujourd'hui que
à deux personnes on est déjà un peu
serré lorsqu'on est au sommet on peut
penser que c'est un endroit très réservé
que le roi dans le roi fait seulement
les honneurs à quelques-uns
ça donne un souverain étranger en visite
dans les parages invités comme
Eric qui ont les honneurs de pénétrer
dans cette tour toujours dans l'espoir
de trouver des financements et d'en
raconter davantage sur l'histoire des
rois de France elle sera peut-être
ouverte un jour au public